and so I guess what that really leads us
to is this quiddity crisis over the last
week where people literally just around
the room and say what do I own that's
got a liquid market attached to it how
can I sell it immediately and I want
that liquidity and we see all of these
assets whether it's gold Treasuries coin
anything correlations are spending Falls
one everything goes down because the
liquidity crisis may be kind of talked
through how that works and then we can
get into how governments have to respond
or the Fed has to respond to those types
of see yeah so the leverage players
always that the lenders always want
collateral in the financial markets and
when they're making loans I guess I'm
technically not always but the vast vast
majority of leverage in the third buy
financial assets and so what happens in
these situations is that when you have
an investor who has to deal Everidge
they're getting a margin call they have
to post more collateral because the
value of the asset securing their loan
just went down just getting a giant
margin call and they're gonna sell
whatever is easy to sell now I talked
about how there were dislocations in the
in that a US Treasury bond market of all
markets last week
I'm liquid and so people were selling
whatever haven't whatever was liquid and
and and whatever hadn't been nailed down
yet and when you see gold go down I
learned this from watching the 2008
financial crisis Gold also plunged in
2008 it a lot of people would have said
oh that's not a safe-haven asset because
it plunged well well oftentimes the
safe-haven assets are the first ones
that are actually sold precisely because
they aren't somewhat tied up in some of
these crazy you know leveraged financial
structures always their leverage has
definitely got an impact on them alright
we can talk about the gold ETF so talk
about all the leverage in the Bitcoin
market but at the at the bottom those
assets are nobodies IOU
they are assets that if you own the real
thing if you own the physical gold or
you own your your private keys for your
crypto assets they're they're yours you
have outright title to those assets
they're nobodies io u--'s and so
oftentimes because of that those assets
are the first ones that get sold and we
certainly saw that in 2008 we certainly
saw that last week we saw a huge
correction in Bitcoin a much lower
correction in gold but golden exactly
act like a supposed safe haven either
now all that said I don't think that one
week matters for either one of those
assets and in fact actually we just
flushed out a lot of the leverage I
think in the in the crypto market I
wouldn't be shocked if some of the
crypto financial institutions didn't
survive last week and we just don't know
it yet and by the way good riddance
the the the the amount of speculative
leverage that was taking place on an
asset that shouldn't be leveraged has
been staggering and the faster we can
clear out that cruft from the market the
better off the market is I I think those
safe haven assets are true safe havens
but that doesn't mean they're gonna be
safe havens every day and they were they
were the easiest thing to sell laffy
when you see gold go down it means that
we're really having serious liquidations
yeah and I think what you alluded to in
2008 I wrote this piece is past week
that
I don't know in 2008 kind of the mid
6-month liquidity crisis period kind of
over the summer goal actually went down
30% during that time period but if you
then zoom out to the entire crisis kind
of ended 2006 to end of 2011 it was up
3x so in there there is that liquidity
crisis you draw it out you know pretty
substantially for the quote-unquote safe
haven asset if you look at Treasuries
for example their season you know the
markets are seizing up again does that
that doesn't mean that it's not a safe
haven type asset or not something that
people want to to get I think Bitcoin
same thing right you see this massive
volatility the other thing that people
have to understand is the market cap of
an asset like Bitcoin it plays into this
it's a smaller market cap it's gonna be
much more volatile but the one data
point I thought was a hunter Horsley
from bitwise I was tweeting this I
thought was really interesting if you
look at the historical volatility of
Bitcoin and let's say the SNP the SNP
going down nine and a half percent on a
relative basis is the equivalent of
Bitcoin going down 51 percent and so
what you saw last week was the SP went
down 9 and then went down 50 percent so
on a relative volatility basis they
actually were just as volatile as you
know each one of them which I thought
was super interesting now that leads us
to ok we get the liquidity crisis every
asset trends towards 1 on the
correlation they all go down obviously
we're going to see monetary stimulus
step in we saw some of that last week
the markets pricing in a hundred percent
likelihood of a rate cut coming up here
I think it's this week talk to us about
how does the government and the Fed
respond to all of this and then we can
talk about kind of the impact that all
these safe-haven assets are kind of
sound money properties yeah well let me
before we talk to how the government's
gonna respond you what you said prompted
a really important thought again this is
not advice but it's just a lens through
which everybody should think about their
own financial situation I would really
encourage everyone to start thinking not
in nominal terms but in real terms what
do I mean by that if the ass if we're in
a deflationary environment and your
assets are going down by less than the
index is going down your cost of living
then you come out ahead
same thing if we're in an inflationary
environment and you're your personal
inflation rate is less than the
inflation rate of the economy or your
that's our going up by more than that
you come out ahead so we've been in the
u.s. really lulled into complacency
because we don't have to think about
foreign exchange rate risk since oils
priced in dollar commodities are priced
in dollars right the rest of the world
has to think about exchange rate risk
all the time it's their norm and so this
whole notion of just because the
numerator is going up the nominal price
is changing that means that my personal
situation follows that uh-uh we need to
start realizing that and I've been
thinking about that for years that the
stock market going up just meant the
dollars value was actually going down
you need to start thinking about that
and and so you know literally the the
best stock market in the last few years
has been Venezuela well that's because
the denominator was going down just
think about the algebra right if all
you're paying attention to is the
numerator you're missing the point
you've got to pay attention to the
denominator and whether the denominator
is his changing value